l'espoir de joe biden c'est que les
ukrainiens gagner la guerre sans la
participation directe des américains oui
c'est ça la stratégie américaine c'est
de faire en sorte qu on vient de le dire
mathieu qu'il ya un renforcement de
l'aide militaire donc là on en est au
total à 1 milliard 600 millions même si
la deuxième tranche doit être approuvée
par le congrès et là il fait un appel du
pied aux élus républicains plus donc il
ya un volet militaire donc plus un volet
économique 500 millions supplémentaires
en plus de 500 millions qui avaient déjà
été versés donc ça fait 1 milliards donc
au total 1 milliard 600 millions des
militaires 1 milliard dead directement
en cache effectivement au gouvernement
ukrainien pour tout simplement continuer
à assurer le fonctionnement de l'état et
de l'administration sur place donc
clairement les états unis ne veulent pas
intervenir directement mais veulent
renforcer la pression renforcer leur
aide à l'ukraine joe biden vient de
parler d'un flux ininterrompu d'armes
qui doit en permanence donc aller vers
l'ukraine les etats unis qui se présente
aussi comme une puissance facilitantes
c'est-à-dire qui permettent aux alliés
européens des etats-unis de fournir eux
également des équipements militaires et
des américains en fêtes comble la
différence en quelque sorte par exemple
avec un pays comme la république tchèque
soit en argent soit en équipements pour
remplacer doré c'est toute une stratégie
indirecte mais qui se renforce au fur et
à mesure de la durée de cette guerre
plus effectivement les nouvelles
sanctions que mature appelé à l'instant
et puis il a terminé sur un note un peu
plus philosophique en gros il a dit
finalement en substance un le combat qui
se mène actuellement c'est aussi un
combat entre cette russie
impérialistes autoritaire et l'occident
qui défend les valeurs de l'état de
droit de la démocratie de la liberté 1
il a dit que le crédit était un pays sur
le front de la liberté est bien dans ce
combat contre la russie et l'occident
joe bailon estime que d'ores et déjà
vladimir poutine en quelque sorte perdu
la main puisqu'il n'a pas pu atteindre
sont ces objectifs ambitieux at il dit
d'avoir la mainmise de moscou sur
l'ensemble de l'ukraine et déjà pour joe
biden c'est un premier échec lourd pour
vladimir poutine où il a salué également
la résistance des ukrainiens ils ont
empêché dit joe biden empêcher poutine
d'accomplir ces atrocités